un perdón para mil 619 presos en mianmar
la amnistía por el año nuevo budista es
habitual pero este año ha sido mucho
menor que los 23.000 de 2021 el evento
congregó a las familias frente a la
prisión de insein pero fuentes de fp
aseguran que los presos políticos
detenidos durante el gobierno de la
actual junta militar no fueron liberados
aunque mi hija sólo tiene 19 años es muy
activa en política estoy orgullosa de
ella
estoy esperando afuera de la prisión con
la esperanza de que sea liberada un
perdón que no ha terminado con la
represión de la junta militar estas
imágenes muestran algunas de las más de
cien aldeas quemadas por el ejército en
los últimos meses pero la represión
también va acompañada de una fuerte
resistencia desde las fuerzas populares
de defensa pero también desde la cultura
como esta comparsa de cantantes y
comediantes que recorre la selva para
hacer pedagogía
pero que la gente apoyará cualquier
movimiento contra los militares puedes
revelarte contra ellos a través del
equipo el electropop o el tanga
la gente está lista para apoyarte en
este tiempo porque todos quieren luchar
contra la dictadura militar
el 1 de febrero de 2021 el ejército dio
un golpe de estado al gobierno de un
sandwich y acusándola de fraude
electoral desde entonces según datos de
una ong local más de 1.700 civiles han
muerto y más de 13.000 personas han sido
arrestadas